المشاهدينا تواصل تقدمها داخل مدينه بخموت
من جهه الشرق بحسب قاده ميدانيين روس ونهر
ضيق يفصل بين الجانبين الروسي والاوكرانيه
القوات الروسيه تحاول عبور من المناطق
الشرقيه للمدينه التي تسيطر عليها لمواصله
التقدم واكمال التطويق المدينه القوات
الاوكرانيه هدمت جسورا رئيسيه فوق النهر
في مسعد لاعاقه التقدم الروسي الى قلب
باخت كما دفعت بالمزيد من التعزيزات
للجبهات الغربيه من النهر وغير مره لجات
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الحرب لتفجير
الجسور لكن الجيش الروسي دائما ما وجد حلا
في الجسور العائمه لتلافي معضله الانتقال
بين ضفاف الانهار في اوكرانيا لكن السؤال
الان ماذا بعد
التقارير تشير الى ان قوات فاجنر والقوات
الروسيه ستستمر في الاندفاع غربا وستكون
خطوتها التاليه
توجه نحو بلده كوستانتيكيبا او التقدم الى
سلوفيا ومحاوله مسك الاراضي لكن بحسب
محللين سيعتمد التقدم الروسي على تسويه كل
المباني التي تواجه القوات بالارض ومحاوله
منع الهجمات الاوكرانيه المضاده ان حصل
هذا ما هي خيارات اوكرانيا اولا قد تلجا
اوكرانيا للقيام بانسحاب تكتيكي
والاستعداد لشن هجوم المضاد خلال الاسابيع
المقبله او قد تلجا لخيار اخر وهو تعزيز
السيطره على قريه خراموف
وتشاسافيار على الجانب الغربي من باخموت
وهي مواقع مرتفعه يمكن استغلالها للهجوم
على اي قوات روسيه تحاول الاقتراب من
المنطقه